bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat hier le parlement a
donné son feu vert à la nomination de
françois villeroy de galop à la fonction
de gouverneur de la banque de france ô
françois villeroy de galhau était le
candidat de françois hollande et sa
candidature faisait débat déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines en effet début
septembre des économistes nombreux ont
signé une tribune dans laquelle ils
dénoncent la possibilité de conflit
d'intérêts en effet françois villeroy de
galhau a été pendant douze ans est bien
l'un des patrons de la bnp paribas il
estime que cela n'est pas compatible
avec le fait d'arriver à la tête de
l'une des institutions de régulation
bancaire les plus importantes ils ont
été rejoints d'ailleurs dans leurs
doutes par de nombreux parlementaires
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche du
côté de ses défenseurs ont trouvé en
revanche est bien de nombreuses ancien
gouverneur de la banque de france parmi
lesquels jean claude trichet il estime
qu'il n'y a pas de contradiction à
passer du privé au public et prend
l'exemple de certains patrons
d'institutions bancaires de régulation
comme mario draghi qui est à la tête de
la bce ou bien encore de l'emblématique
paul volcker dans les années 70 ce qui
était à la tête de la fed américaine et
qui était passé également du privé au
public en tout cas hier françois
villeroy de galhau a convaincu les
parlementaires qui ont adopté la
possibilité de sa nomination à la tête
de la banque de france à une très large
majorité tout de suite je vous propose
de revenir à son grand oral
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de votre accueil il vous revient
effectivement
d'apprécier si je peux remplir une
mission dont je mesure toute la
responsabilité au service de notre pays
je me réjouis que cette procédure qui
est exercée pour la première fois
s'agissant de la banque de france donne
des garanties de transparence et de
contrôle qui confère ensuite à un mandat
davantage de légitimité et
d'impartialité
je crois à la démocratie et au respect
de nos institutions
voilà pourquoi j'ai décidé depuis la
proposition du président public de
réserver aux parlementaires et à eux
seuls
mon intervention ainsi que les réponses
à vos questions légitimes sereinement
puis je dire que cette règle n'a pas
toujours été facile
ces dernières semaines mais elle
s'imposait je suis donc heureux que le
temps de cette audition soit venu je
voudrais brièvement commencer par un
volet personnel avant de venir sur les
missions de la banque de france et la
première vision que j'en ai
pour apprécier mon aptitude à cette
fonction vous avez à juger d'une
personne de sa compétence et de son
indépendance
sur la personne pour aller au delà de
certaines étiquettes parfois hâtivement
collet puis simplement vous donner deux
ou trois éclairages sur mon histoire je
suis un homme de l'est né à strasbourg
et dont les racines familiales sont
depuis longtemps en lorraine et même en
sarre autrefois terre française est
aujourd'hui de l'autre côté de la
frontière nous avons choisi de toujours
rester français ceci crée un lien encore
plus profond avec mon pays et je suis en
même temps un européen de conviction et
de pratique en allemagne ou plus
récemment en italie
je suis avant tout un homme de service
public j'ai passé déjà vingt ans de ma
vie professionnelle marquée notamment
par deux grands engagements la
construction de l'union économique et
monétaire à paris à bruxelles la réforme
de la direction générale des impôts que
j'ai eu l'honneur de diriger
en 2003 quand je suis allé en entreprise
j'ai dit que c'était pour moi une autre
façon servir notre pays et la force de
son économie alors il paraît que
l'expression a un peu surpris des deux
côtés de la frontière entre secteur
public et entreprise mais oui je crois
qu'il ne faut pas à l'excès opposé ces
deux mondes j'ai appris à bien connaître
les entrepreneurs mais l'intérêt pour la
chose publique ne m'a jamais quitté
j'espère être enfin un homme de
conviction sans prétendre donner de
leçons avec humilité mais je crois à la
responsabilité sociale de chacun mais
d'abord des dirigeants y compris des
dirigeants économiques je crois à
l'éthique y compris en matière
financière j'ai toujours dit ce que je
pensais des excès de la finance et de
certaines rémunérations
je me suis engagé pour le développement
du microcrédit et de l'entrepreneuriat
social
je crois au débat d'idées et au dialogue
entre des personnes respectueuses de
leurs différences ce dialogue est sans
doute pour notre pays aujourd'hui avec
toutes ces peurs et le drame du chômage
le défi le plus difficile vous le
ressentez plus quotidiennement encore
que moi
sur mes compétences
la question n'a évidemment pas
d'inventer une querelle entre les
inspecteurs et les docteurs c'est plutôt
la variété de mon parcours professionnel
construit cependant autour d'une
continuité d'engagement qui m'a je
l'espère bien préparé pour cette mission
outre les connaissances européennes et
en économie j'ai aussi enseigné dix ans
celle ci il y a sans doute 3 savoir
faire spécifique que j'ai davantage
développés y compris par mon expérience
bancaire le management de grandes
équipes et d'un réseau la connaissance
du terrain des entreprises et des pme et
de leur financement et enfin le sens où
le goût de la pédagogie sur des sujets
rapidement trop technique
le rapport que j'ai remis fin août sur
le financement de l'investissement
montrent je l'espère cette valeur
ajoutée
mais cela m'amène à la dernière question
personnelle ce plus de compétences
risque-t-il d'entraîner un moins
d'indépendance
cette question de l'indépendance est
naturellement légitime et je les prises
très au sérieux j'ai d'abord voulu
garantir qu'il n'y aurait jamais de
situation de conflit d'intérêts tel que
vous l'avez défini à l'article 2 de la
loi de 2013 sur la transparence de la
vie publique que jamais ne puisse
exister un intérêt privé je cite de
nature à influencer ou paraître
influencer l'exercice indépendant
impartial et objectif de mes
responsabilités
après avoir examiné le plus
rigoureusement possible l'ensemble des
dispositions existant en droit français
c'est la lettre que j'ai tenus madame la
présidente à vous faire parvenir dès le
9 septembre je n'aurais plus aucun
intérêt présent ni différé dans bnp
paribas ni dans aucune autre banque ou
institution financière et j'ai renoncé
pour cela définitivement à tous mes
droits financiers les décisions
individuelles concernant les grandes
banques ont par ailleurs été
significativement réduite par le
transfert de leur surveillance à
francfort depuis le 1er novembre dernier
je m'engage cependant à titre de
précaution supplémentaire à ne
participer à aucune décision
individuelle d'aucune sorte concernant
bnp paribas dans les deux ans suivant
mon départ
mais l'indépendance c'est plus que cette
absence de tout conflit d'intérêts c'est
veiller à ce que la réglementation
collective du secteur banque et
assurance soit toujours prises en
fonction de l'intérêt général
j'ai lu parfois là dessus que je
risquais d'être prisonnier de la finance
si j'étais nommé c'est extrêmement mal
me connaître j'ai mes limites comme
chacun mais je suis un homme libre et je
suis un homme droit et donc je déciderai
en fonction seulement de ce que je crois
être bon pour notre pays et son économie
je m'appuierai pour cela sur l'
expertise forte des équipes de la banque
de france
et sur ce que je connais du secteur et
je crois que c'est un atout l'exemple
des pays étrangers montre combien cette
expérience peut apporter pour des
banquiers centraux
je voudrais dire que l'indépendance pour
conclure sur ce point essentiel
ce sont des règles les plus rigoureuse
possible mais aussi un caractère et une
éthique
c'est sur ces trois composantes que vous
apprécierez la confiance à m'accorder et
si vous le faites ce sont ces trois
composantes des règles un caractère une
éthique que j'aurai ensuite à appliquer
chaque jour pour défendre le bien commun
que la monnaie ceci m'amène omission
ses missions s'exercent bien sûr dans le
contexte nouveau créé par leur haut
depuis 16 ans et l'union bancaire depuis
l'an dernier mais la banque de france
joue toujours un rôle essentiel pour
l'économie française et européenne
alors je ne prétendrai pas aujourd'hui
vous en donner déjà une lecture achevée
et je serais heureux dans l'avenir
d'avoir sur ces sujets un dialogue aussi
fréquent et complet que possible avec
votre commission mais je résumerais ma
vision des missions de la banque de
france autour de trois grands objectifs
la stratégie monétaire le service
économique pour la collectivité
nationale la stabilité financière en
meilleure prévention des crises
la stratégie monétaire d'abord et bien
sûr l'euro on oublie parfois
repose sur un système fédéral efficace
composé de la banque centrale européenne
et des banques centrales nationales de
s'être système la banque de france est
le pilier français et elle a donc tout
son rôle à jouer que ce soit en amont
dans les débats et décisions de
politique monétaire qui appartiennent au
conseil des gouverneurs comme en aval
dans la réalisation des opérations qui
lui incombe pour notre territoire ainsi
que la monnaie fiduciaire les billets je
crois que la politique monétaire active
aujourd'hui menée avec mario draghi et
la bonne pour tendre vers une inflation
proche de 2% et elle est nécessaire
aussi pour soutenir la croissance même
si elle ne peut y suffire
il faut à la croissance des réformes
dans chaque pays dont le nôtre il faut
un renforcement de la zone euro et il ne
faut pas renoncer à l'ambition d'un
meilleur ordre monétaire mondial
je voudrais ajouter que notre monnaie ce
sont bien sûr les règles des traités
mais c'est à mes yeux beaucoup plus
qu'un outil technique une bonne monnaies
comme l'euro doit porter pour nos
concitoyens des valeurs essentielles de
confiance et de justice
au titre de cette stratégie monétaire je
veux aussi poursuivre l'ambition incarné
par christian noyer d'une banque de
france en position de leadership
européen en particulier sur les
opérations de marché où les moyens de
paiement
j'ai parlé ensuite du service économique
à la collectivité nationale alors à ce
titre la banque de france doit apporter
notamment aux élus le meilleur
diagnostic possible sur la conjoncture
la situation des entreprises les
financements en soutien du développement
elle doit rendre des services concrets
aux particuliers à commencer par les
plus défavorisés
qu'il s'agisse du traitement du
surendettement de l'accès aux comptes
bancaires de la protection et
l'éducation financière des consommateurs
et elle est de même au service des pme à
travers la cotation et la médiation du
crédit
ses missions de service économique
s'ancre très heureusement sur le terrain
je compte aller personnellement dans
chacune des nouvelles régions dans la
première année de mes fonctions pour
rencontrer les équipes de la banque mais
aussi les acteurs publics et privés dans
les territoires et en retour cet ancrage
est clair me semble-t-il la stratégie
monétaire
si je puis dire la banque de france à
cette grande chance d'avoir à la fois la
tête dans l'europe et les pieds sur le
terrain et je vis de développer encore
ce lien
enfin la stabilité financière
cette mission s'est évidemment renforcée
depuis la crise financière et ses
ravages
elle a son volet individuel pour
garantir la sécurité de l'épargné la
supervision des assurances et des
banques avec pour les principales de
celle ci le grand progrès de l'union
bancaire un système financier sain sert
notre pays
mais la stabilité financière exige aussi
surtout un volet collectif le
renforcement de la réglementation
financière et la surveillance des
risques d'enchaînements dit
macroprudentielle un travail complexe
considérable indispensable a été menée
depuis 2009 à bâle à bruxelles à paris
des deux bords opposés ce travail est
souvent critiquée mais excessivement les
règles du jeu n'ont objectivement
plus rien à voir avec celle de l'avant
crise les banques ont dû renforcer leur
protection
et à linverse bâle iii ne pèse pas
aujourd'hui à mon sens sur la croissance
pour autant nous devons rester très
vigilants pour l'avenir ceci suppose
notamment une présence active dans les
discussions de balle de la france comme
de la zone euro qui partagent en général
le même modèle de financement par des
banques intégré
stratégie service stabilité voici le
triangle fondateur des missions de la
banque de france et c'est un triangle
dynamique puisque chacune des missions
nourrit les deux autres encore faut-il
pour cela deux conditions transversale
du succès par lesquels je voudrais
conclure
la première condition est de contribuer
encore davantage au débat économique
rigoureux dans notre pays nos défis
économiques sont immenses nous le savons
notre culture économique collectif passe
pour être faible nos affrontements sont
souvent stéréotypées nos cloisons sont
trop étanche entre responsables publics
entre preneur recherche économique le
pays a pourtant une communauté
d'économistes parmi la plus reconnue au
monde la banque de france a en son sein
beaucoup de talent et de données pour
nourrir avec toute cette communauté
extérieur l'éclairage des problèmes et
la recherche de leurs solutions je
m'engagerai en ce sens
la seconde clé du succès ce sont les
équipes elles-mêmes de la banque de
france et leur management ce sont
aujourd'hui douze mille hommes et femmes
très attachés à leur métier est reconnu
par tous pour leur fiabilité et leur
professionnalisme
la moitié hors des services centraux
dans le réseau pour l'essentiel ou pour
la fabrication des billets la banque est
engagé vous le savez dans un plan résolu
d'adaptation ce réseau qui combine
efficacité et visibilité dans chaque
département mais au delà il y as me
semble-t-il un bel horizon de management
la banque de france peut et doit être au
sein du service public exemplaire dans
la transition des générations la
modernisation de ses méthodes de travail
l'ouverture de sa culture
la banque de france peut je crois
regarder l'avenir avec ambition parce
qu'elle est forte de son nom et de son
histoire mais plus encore parce que ses
missions en font un instrument
exceptionnel au service d'une monnaie
fiable et plus largement d'une
croissance saine et d'un emploi durable
telles sont les finalités qui m'anime
rond si vous me confier cette
responsabilité
pour notre pays merci merci beaucoup
merci pour cette présentation et je
voudrais vous poser une première
question avant de passer la parole à
notre reporter général autour de l'union
bancaire nous savons qu'elle devait
reposer sur trois piliers une super
vision commune une résolution commune et
une garantie des dépôts mutualisés si
les deux premiers piliers sont déjà mis
en place ou en cours le troisième semble
au point mort l'allemagne n'appréciant
pas beaucoup l'idée de mutualiser son
système de garantie des dépôts
considérez-vous que l'union bancaire est
crédible et permet véritablement de
réduire le lien entre le risque
souverain elle risque bancaire tant
qu'un épargnant découvert que par son
système de garantie des dépôts nationale
il faut il attendre la mise en place
complète des règles de résolution en
particulier le renflouement interne
avant d'envisager une mutualisation des
fonds de garantie des dépôts et je vais
poser la question je vais donner tout de
suite à albéric de montgolfier
rapporteur général et vous me répondrez
aux deux merci à la présidente merci
beaucoup pour cette présentation ma
première question n'est pas du tout liée
à vos anciennes fonctions puisqu'elle
concerne des questions à l'international
puisque et visiter en charge du marché
domestique en france
les banques françaises sont impliquées à
62,2 d'affaires à l'international
notamment les questions de transactions
avec des pays sous embargo c'était le
cas pour bnp c'est le cas pour le crédit
agricole ou des questions de blanchiment
régulièrement est ce que le gouverneur
de la banque de france devrait proposer
des mesures de nature à prévenir à
l'avenir ce type de situation est ce que
il faut renforcer les règles sur la
prévention des transactions avec des
pays sous embargo ou alors sur les
questions de blanchiment dans laquelle
qui reviennent régulièrement mais je
précise bien que ça n'a pas du tout lié
à ma fonction puisque vous étiez dans
chaque marché domestique je viens de
paix la deuxième question vous l'avez
quand c'est elle évoqua l'instant cette
question qui préoccupe très
régulièrement la commission des finances
puisque nous avons beaucoup
auditionné nous avons beaucoup travaillé
sur les questions de renforcement de
sécurité sur la solvabilité des banques
est ce que toutes ces règles le
prudentielles
je pense à bâle iii nos ratios de
solvabilité sont pas finalement de
nature à
contraindre un peu trop l'économie
diminuer le financement de l'économie et
notamment votre position sur un éventuel
bâle 4 voilà et puis la question aussi
qui nous inquiète beaucoup notamment par
rapport aux taux souverains comment
appréciez-vous le risque de remontée des
taux on est suspendu à la décision de la
fed et de ce point de vue qu'elle doit
être votre sens la politique de la
banque centrale
face à ce risque éventuel de remontée
des taux merci
oui je vais essayer de répondre le plus
rapidement possible ces questions qui
sont des heures essentielles
madame la présidente sur les trois
piliers de l'union bancaire alors je
vous rejoins tout à fait sur l'existence
des trois piliers je voudrais néanmoins
salué le formidable progrès qu'est la
construction des deux premiers
il ya deux ans rien de ceux ci
n'existait et peut-être même des dettes
imaginables la supervision est
opérationnel depuis le 1er novembre
dernier à francfort la résolution le
sera loris truc c'est à bruxelles dans
le subtil construction européenne à
compter du 1er janvier prochain ce qui
veut dire alors c'est un cas beaucoup
plus exceptionnel et dont j'espère avec
vous qu'il ne se produira pas mais si
jamais une grande banque française se
trouvait en procédure de résolution
c'est le conseil de résolution unique
assiégeant à bruxelles qui prendraient
les décisions
la mise en oeuvre appartenant il s'agit
simplement d'une mise en oeuvre
appartenant à la banque de france
sur la garantie des dépôts c'est
effectivement un sujet difficile alors
là nous parlons de la partie qui est
sous cent mille euros puisque au dessus
de 100 mille euros il n'y a pas de
garantie et c'est réglé par la
résolution et le fait que maintenant il
est tout à fait clair que les créanciers
seront appelés plutôt que les
contribuables à combler les besoins
financiers de la résolution ce qui
encore une fois est un énorme progrès la
commission européenne vient de faire des
propositions à la matière et monsieur
juncker s'est engagé en faveur de la
garantie des dépôts je ne préjugerait
peut-être pas avec trop de précision de
ce que peut donner la discussion qui
s'annonce effectivement très difficile
avec l'allemagne et pas seulement avec
elle je crois qu'il faut calibrer
précisément quel est le besoin en la
matière la seule réflexion
que je voudrais faire c'est qu'il ya un
lien entre la complétude du 2e pilier
c'est à dire la résolution est le besoin
d'une garantie complètement harmonisée
des dépôts si on a une résolution qui
fonctionne bien et qui couvre les
besoins ce qui n'est pas encore tout à
fait le cas le deuxième pilier n'est pas
totalement terminée il peut y avoir
peut-être un peu plus de souplesse sur
le troisième pilier mais c'est une des
discussions importantes qui va nous
occuper dans les années qui viennent
pardon de ce nous qui ne préjuge de rien
mais
monsieur le rapporteur général à propos
de votre question sur les affaires à
l'international donc je voudrais
préciser ça va sans le dire mais
peut-être encore mieux en le disant
qu'ils se trouvent que comme vous l'avez
dit j'étais en charge chez bnp paribas
j'ai eu diverses responsabilités mais je
n'ai jamais ni à l'époque des fêtes ni à
l'époque des négociations avec les
autorités américaines ni ensuite bien
sûr sur les sanctions étaient mêlés aux
contentieux de bnp paribas avec les
autorités américaines et je
m'abstiendrai bien sûr de tout
commentaire sur ce contentieux alors je
crois que les affaires que vous avez
cités pour les banques françaises et que
je connais pas nécessairement dans le
détail sont un sujet générale des
banques occidentales c'est que la
problématique de ce qu'on appelle la
conformité quelquefois du respect des
règles ou d'un mauvais mot anglais
l'accomplît yen s'est considérablement
renforcée et du coup les banques ont dû
à la fois acquitté des pénalités très
importantes y compris les banques
américaines elles mêmes pour lequel ça
se chiffre en dizaines de milliards de
dollars et renforcer énormément leurs
procédures internes de prévention je
crois que ce travail est en cours les
équipes de conformité dans chacune des
grandes banques françaises ont
considérablement augmenté et je lirai
d'une phrase qui pouvait y avoir dans le
passé des zones grises ou des
incertitudes du droit ceci est
totalement finie tout ce qui n'est pas
explicitement autorisé par la
législation internationale et l'ensemble
des législations nationales y compris la
gestion américaine doit être considéré
comme pro ib
c'est un changement qui d'ailleurs pour
le commerce avec un certain nombre de
pays émergents peut introduire des
questions mais je crois que là il ne
peut pas y avoir
la moindre faiblesse et il me semble de
ce que j'en sais aujourd'hui que les
banques françaises sont effectivement
très engagés pour renforcer
considérablement leur conformité
vous avez posé ensuite la question des
règles prudentielles
alors j'ai évoqué dans mon propos
liminaire le fait qu'il me semblait
qu'aujourd'hui bâle iii c'est à dire les
règles applicables aujourd'hui
contrairement à certaines craintes
affichées les branques c'est vrai ça
fait partie des points il y en a
certains nombres ou mon appréciation
peut être différente de celle de
l'industrie bancaire
aujourd'hui bâle iii ne mord pas sur la
croissance y compris il ya diverses
raisons à cela mais y compris parce que
la politique monétaire a des effets
beaucoup qui est favorable à des effets
beaucoup beaucoup plus importants que
les éventuels effets négatifs de bâle
iii sur la disponibilité du crédit et le
coût du crédit
la question est effectivement plus
difficile pour demain sur ce que
certains appellent déjà bâle 4 est une
appellation un peu agrégé mais c'est
vrai que sont en discussion à bâle un
certain nombre de règles portant des
noms quelquefois un peu un peu barbare
le thi lac qui est un mécanisme de
coussin amortisseur le ratio de levier
sur les risques non pondéré la révision
des risques opérationnels
veux pas rentrer dans le détail
mais ces règles peuvent pénaliser un peu
plus spécifiquement les banques
européennes et les banques françaises
que les banques américaines
non pas parce que les banques
américaines chercheraient à ruser avec
ses règles mrv ces règles sont plus
naturels par rapport à la réglementation
américaine existante que par rapport à
la réglementation européenne et
française actuelle et donc je crois que
là-dessus quand j'ai parlé de vigilance
ça s'applique à ces nouvelles règles en
discussion je crois qu'il va falloir
trouver le bon équilibre entre le
renforcement de la sécurité financière
qui reste un impératif premier et les
éventuels effets économiques négatifs
une des propositions que j'ai faites
dans mon rapport c'est qu'on puisse
réactivé à bâle une instance
internationale d'évaluation des effets
économiques prévisibles des règles aussi
surprenant que cela puisse paraître une
telle instance à exister en 2010 au
début de bâle iii mais elle ne s'est
plus réuni depuis je ne dit d'ailleurs
pas que le sujet techniquement simple
parce que les effets économiques sont
difficiles à mesurer et il ya divers
modèles possibles divers scénarios
possibles mais je crois qu'on ne peut
pas vis-à-vis des responsables publics
et des législateurs que vous êtes en
rester simplement à dire bah écoutez on
ne sait pas où
si vous me permettez trivialement
circulez ya rien à voir il ya un certain
nombre de travaux économiques qui ont
été faits je crois que c'est important
cueillez ces évaluations ex ante et dans
les instances d'évaluation et qu'ensuite
vous puissiez apprécier
sur le risque de remontée des taux je
pense que votre question visaient les
états unis
donc il y aura probablement remontée des
taux américains
je me garderai de faire un pronostic de
calendrier ce qui paraît extrêmement
probable c'est que ce voile à cette
inflexion ce point de retournement de la
politique monétaire américaine ne
changera pas la politique monétaire
européenne
je crois que mario draghi et le conseil
des gouverneurs ont été très clairs
là-dessus leur intention est de
maintenir durablement
durablement n'étant pas chiffré mais des
taux bas en europe je note d'ailleurs
d'ores et déjà que quand on regarde les
taux longs les taux à 10 ans ils sont et
ce n'est pas très souvent souligné ils
sont aujourd'hui beaucoup plus bas en
europe qu'ils ne sont aux etats unis on
est de l'ordre pour pour l'état allemand
à 0 6% aujourd'hui 1% en france alors
qu'on est à plus de 2% aux etats-unis
donc nous avons déjà de fait sur les
taux longs cette déconnexion des taux
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas un phénomène
entièrement réjouissant parce qu'elle
correspond aussi au fait que l'économie
américaine est plus avancée sur le
chemin de croissance que l'économie
européenne
merci beaucoup je propose de prendre les
questions par 3 si vous voulez bien dans
un premier temps je vais donner la
parole à michel bouvard ensuite richard
yong et françois marc et si vous voulez
bien leur apporter une réponse je vous
en remercie donc michel bouvard oui mais
merci merci de votre présentation et
d'autres exposés vous avez indiqué qu'à
votre sens bâle iii ne faisait pas sur
la croissance on a compris au travers de
l'explication venez donné que le propos
était un peu plus nuancé et c'était
simplement un problème d'équilibré
l'une des questions de fond sur les
problèmes d'encadrement bancaires et de
normes prudentielles c'est aussi les
modes de financement différent de
l'économie du continent européen comme
vous l'avez rappelé et de l'économie
nord américaine
et quelle attitude finalement considérez
vous que l'on doive avoir dans la suite
des discussions
par rapport à ce que sont les exigences
parfois des partenaires américains dans
ces négociations et avec le sujet
derrière d'une fête une grande partie du
système de financement
américain du système bancaire américaine
et échappe à toute régulation ça c'est
la première question la deuxième
question
concerne le continent africain le
continent africain chacun considère
aujourd'hui que c'est un continent qui a
appelé à avoir une forte croissance il
ya sur le continent africain le franc
cfa qui reste avec une parité fixe et
par rapport à l'euro est ce que vous
pensez aujourd'hui que c'est un atout
que c'est un handicap est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut que cela évolue ou pas
et puis la dernière question a trait aux
taux d'intérêt qui sont bas est-ce que
puisque le dans vos fonctions au travers
de la cpr vous aurez également avoir un
contrôle en termes
prudentielles sur le secteur assurantiel
est ce que vous considérez que ce soit
supportable durablement par le secteur
assurantiel
merci beaucoup michel bouvard richard
yong il sera suivi de françois marc
président le gouverneur de la banque de
france siègent au conseil des
gouverneurs de la bce donc vous aurez un
mot important à dire dans la politique
menée par la banque centrale européenne
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous approuve y est les orientations et
l'action menée par mario draghi en
particulier j'imagine vous aviez en tête
la politique monétaire
mais la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est quels sont les effets de cette
politique aujourd'hui on voit
l'objectif était de monter le taux
d'inflation à un niveau proche de 2% or
on voit qu'aujourd'hui nous nous
traînons si j'ose dire à 0 1% et 0 2%
donc pour l'instant elle n'a pas encore
porter pleinement ses fruits ma question
c'est comment est-ce que vous verriez la
chose que la proposition feriez-vous au
conseil des gouverneurs de la bce est ma
seconde question n'a rien à voir avec la
politique monétaire mais vous avez
publié un livre il ya pas très longtemps
sa sont prémonitoires peut-être qu'ils
s'appellent l'espérance d'un européen
d'impôt titre est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire les deux trois grandes idées
que vous avez défendu développer dans
cet ouvrage aussi à richard yong
françois marc oui l'europe et aussi
merci voilà pourquoi
je voulais vous interroger sur un sujet
qui est d'actualité et que
l'agefi a désigné comme le cas de
conscience des régulateurs je veux
parler de la finance de l'ombre du
shadow banking on sait qu'aujourd'hui
la moitié au moins des activités
financières
sont non régulés puisque se déroulant
dans le champ de du shadow banking
ou non qu'on sait les raisons de ce
développement et certains pensent que
c'est parce que les règles ont été trop
strictes sur la régulation bancaire que
s'est développée alentours un certain
nombre d'activités plus risqués pour
permettre de satisfaire les clients et
de leur offrir un taux de rendement un
peu plus intéressant donc une prise de
risque et
les states of international finance
parle d'un risque systémique donc c'est
un vrai problème sans doute alors j'ai
vu que le gouverneur actuel de la banque
de france s'est exprimé sur le sujet je
crois bien que c'est hier ou dans les
passes et puis tu es plutôt mesurée
concernant les possibilités de
régulation donc la question vous pose
c'est de connaître un peu votre
sentiment et votre doctrine personnel
sur ce sujet dès lors qu'
il s'agit ici
de d'acteurs qui ont pour vocation de
contourner la réglementation bancaire et
financière pour générer plus de profits
quel est votre point de vue sur la
régulation nécessaire ou pas à quel
degré d'intensité de cette sphère
financière parallèle
merci à françois marque tom suivi droite
gallo vous avez la parole
donc je vais partir de la question de
monsieur bouvard sur le mode de
financement différent des économies
américaine et européenne et si monsieur
le sénateur mark me le permets j
rattacherait la question du shadow
banking parce que je crois qu'il ya un
grand lien il ya un grand lien entre les
deux
d'abord le constat et j'ai eu l'occasion
de mettre dans mon rapport à certain
nombre de chiffres est incontestable
nous avons des modes de financement très
différent des deux côtés de l'atlantique
j'appelle d'ailleurs votre attention sur
le fait qu' on regarde toujours le
financement par dette et en gros il ya
en zone euro 20% du financement par
dette qui se fait sur les marchés 80%
par les banques alors qu'aux états unis
c'est 25% par les banques 75 % par les
marchés donc pratiquement l' inverse il
ya une autre grande différence et nous
n'en parlerons pas aujourd'hui
c'est le financement par fonds propres
ce qui se trouve que le financement par
fonds propres par action est beaucoup
plus important aux états unis et je
crois que ça fait partie d'une économie
d'innovation donc c'est une question
aussi que nous avons à nous poser si je
reviens sur le financement par dette
j'ai marqué très clairement dans mon
rapport et je n'ai pas de raison de
changer de conviction dans une fonction
futur demain que je me méfie du discours
sur la désintermédiation qu'on a
beaucoup entendu à propos de l'économie
européenne je crois qu'il ya eu un peu
d'excès
du paquet barnier monsieur barnier
lui-même n'a d'ailleurs jamais dit que
l'objectif était d'aller vers un modèle
américain de passer de 80 % bancaire à
on ne sait pas quels chiffres d'ailleurs
est ce qu'il faudrait passer à 50 à 40 à
25 à qu'eric tout ça n'a aucun sens je
ne crois pas à la désintermédiation
forcé d'en haut je crois à la
diversification
conduite par la demande selon les
besoins des entreprises je crois pour
les entreprises surtout pour les deux
pays mais aussi pour certaines pme c'est
un atout supplémentaire de pouvoir dire
je continue à me financés par ma banque
si je le souhaite il faut bien sûr
garder cette possibilité mais je peux
faire appel au marché je peux faire
appel à des placements privés qui se
développe très vite où je peux faire
appel à des plateformes de financement
participatif qui sont de plus petite
taille mais dont nous savons qu'elles
sont treize ans
en cours si j'ose dire où en vue et donc
il me paraît essentiel que la
réglementation soit cohérente avec
ceux-ci ouvrir la diversification c'est
une bonne chose forcer la
désintermédiation je crois que ce serait
une erreur il me semble que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
de la réglementation et je crois
d'ailleurs que la demande des
entreprises ça relativement forte pour
cette diversification moi j'ai rencontré
beaucoup d'entreprises de taille mais
enfin de tei ou de pme à l'occasion de
mon rapport en france comme en europe et
elle souhaite avoir cette liberté
élargir les touches du piano si j'ose
dire
le tête à tête avec la banque c'est bien
la pluralité du choix c'est encore mieux
alors la question
je crois que ceci pose deux questions
par rapport aux états unis la première
c'est qu'il ne faut pas qu'à bâle
s'impose une vision correspondant au
seul modèle de financement américain ça
j'ai parlé de présence active à bâle en
réponse à la question de monsieur le
rapporteur général tout à l'heure sur
balles quatre voilà il y a vraiment
aucune raison que valve
transpose purement et simplement la
réglementation américaine dans
l'ensemble des pays du g20 et puis la
deuxième question c'est celle monsieur
le sénateur que vous avez posé c'est que
dans ce modèle de financement diversifié
il ne faut pas qu'il y ait des trous de
la régulation qui représentent des
risques alors si vous me donnez deux
minutes là dessus et autorisé mois ne
pas être tout à fait définitif
je reviendrai volontiers parler de ces
sujets écrit mais je voudrais faire de
réflexion la première c'est que
l'appellation de shed au banking
départ lente et très à la mode elle a
quelquefois elle a un peu perdu en
précision ce qu'elle a gagné en
notoriété
et il arrive à des banquiers je les aime
bien mais d'utiliser le terme shadow
banking et quelques excès c'est à dire
serait shadow banking tout ce qui n'est
pas banque et devrait être soumis à la
même règle à sion que les banques tout
ce qui n'est pas banque ça je crois que
c'est une vision excessive du sujet par
contre c'est ma deuxième réflexion
je crois qu'il faut absolument éviter ce
que vous avez évoquées dans votre
question c'est à dire qu'il ya des
arbitrages réglementaires et des masses
de financement qui se déplacent du
secteur régulé vers le secteur non
régulés alors par rapport à cela il me
semble quand je regarde
il ya quatre grandes série
d'intermédiaires financiers
théoriquement de par le monde il ya les
banques les laurence les gestionnaires
d'actifs et les fonds de pension dans le
cas français nous allons oublier les
fonds de pension reste les trois
premiers banques et assurances je crois
que le travail a été en gros fait ça
veut pas dire que on est au bout qui a
pas des sujets supplémentaires bâle 4
révision de seuils va de et cetera mais
la grande question qui se pose et ça je
crois que c'est la priorité à
l'intérieur de cet ensemble un peu floue
peut-être parfois du shadow banking
c'est la régulation des gestionnaires
d'actifs alors les asset managers
américains yves perrier qui est le
dirigeant d'amundi le plus grand
gestionnaire d'actifs france est le seul
acteur de taille mondiale qui soit en
europe et qui est en france a lui-même
pris parti courageusement pour un
renforcement de cette réglementation et
il se trouve que c'est la priorité du
conseil de stabilité financière à bâle
alors il ya évidemment je parle
librement dans le cadre de cette
commission d intérêt assez différent des
deux côtés de l'atlantique
mais mark carney qui est le gouverneur
de la banque d'angleterre et le
président du comité de bâle a l'air tout
à fait décidé à avancer là dessus je
crois qu'il est très souhaitable je les
écris d'ailleurs d'arriver à un accord
d'ici 2016 sur les gestionnaires
d'actifs pour autant ça ne sera pas la
transposition pure et simple de la
réglementation bancaire par exemple
mettre des obligations de capital très
importante les gestionnaires d'actifs ça
n'a sans doute pas beaucoup de chance
mais m sans rentrer trop dans les
tailles des règles de liquidité
surveiller les effets de levier qui peut
y avoir chez un gestionnaire d'actifs
avoir des stress tests aussi puissants
que ceux qui ont été appliqués aux
banques ça oui je crois que c'est une
priorité pour bâle et et pour éviter ces
arbitrages réglementaires
sur le cfa monsieur l'ordinateur j'avoue
que votre question me touche pas je sais
pas si c'est dans le détail de mon cv
mais mon premier emploi à la direction
du trésor a été le bureau de la zone
franc donc
j'y ai cru je vous que j'y crois
toujours
entre temps est intervenu c'était il ya
longtemps donc entre temps est
intervenue une dévaluation de 1994 qui
me semble je le dis avec une certaine
prudence
avoir consolidé la zone franc et avoir
rendu compatible la stabilité monétaire
croissance qui était le grand défi que
nous pouvions avoir
on se chie sous réserve du fait que
honnêtement je n'ai pas regardé le sujet
récemment mais je crois que la zone
franc est un atout pour le développement
de ces pays d'afrique francophone et
bien sûr un lien très important entre la
france et ces pays
sur les taux d'intérêt bas
je crois qu'il ya là effectivement
un point à suivre de près pour le
secteur assurantiel vous avez peut-être
vu que le haut conseil de stabilité
financière dans sa réunion de début
septembre le conseil de stabilité
financière est en 1 est vrai progrès
issu de la loi bancaire de 2013 a appelé
l'attention sur la nécessité d'une
baisse ordonné des rendements servis sur
l'assurance vie
voilà nous savons tous est un sujet
sensible commercialement et puis
vis-à-vis des clients mais voilà il ne
faut pas que les rendements servis par
l'assurance-vie soit trop piloté par le
passé il faut qu'ils anticipent un peu
la baisse moyenne sur le stock alors
après tout est affaire de pilotage en
finesse puisque nous savons aussi que le
plus grand risque qui pourrait exister
pour l'assurance vie c'est au contraire
une remontée brutale des taux qui
diminue la valeur des portefeuilles
obligataires mais voilà je crois qu'un
pilotage un peu progressif en finesse de
la baisse actuelle est par ailleurs
suivis d'une période qui ne sera pas une
remontée brutale des taux bas c'est pas
du tout l'orientation de la politique
monétaire
doit doit nous permettre de bien gérer
ses enjeux
monsieur young à propos des effets de la
politique du conseil des gouverneurs
alors vous avez raison il n'y a pas eu
d'effet immédiat sur l'inflation en zone
euro voilà je note juste qu'on est passé
d'un territoire négatif que nous avions
encore au début de cette année à un
territoire très faiblement positif
puisque l'inflation au mois d'août en
zone euro comme en france était de +0 1
mai
donc la tendance va dans le bon sens
pour se rapprocher des 2 % mais on est
encore assez loin du compte alors nous
savons qu'une partie de l'explication
tient au prix du pétrole extrêmement bas
aux prix des matières premières et des
produits alimentaires qu'ils aient pu
baisser donc si on regarde l'inflation
hors ces effets produits alimentaires et
énergie elle est plutôt entre +0 6 et +0
9 dans la plupart des pays de la zone
euro mais s'est pas encore
et évidemment la cible je crois pour
autant que cette politique a eu des
effets d'ores et déjà des anticipations
d'inflation quand même remonter et les
anticipations sont aujourd'hui d'une
inflation qui seraient entre un ennemi
plus vers la fin 2010 est donc on se
rapprocherait de la cible est par
ailleurs
cette politique a eu des effets sur la
baisse des taux de financement bien sûr
des états et indirectement des
entreprises et des ménages et je crois
que c'est bon pour la croissance
européenne et elle a eu aussi des effets
qui sont sans doute les plus sensibles
sur le taux de change puisque ça a été
anticipé en partie par les marchés mais
ça s'est tenue on est je crois
aujourd'hui
1,12 dollar pour un euro alors qu'on
était entre 1,30 et 1,40 au début 2014
donc ça c'est évidemment un élément
assez important pour la compétitivité et
la croissance européenne donc je n'ai
pas aujourd'hui de propositions
supplémentaires à faire mais je prends
votre question je note simplement que
mario draghi et les membres du conseil
des gouverneurs ont marqué extrêmement
clairement qu'ils seraient flexible
adaptable s'il fallait faire plus
notamment sur ce programme de rachats
d'actifs si il fallait en augmenter le
rythme en prolonger la durée je crois
qu'ils ont montré en la matière un grand
pragmatisme
bon je ne sais pas si je saurai vous
résumer l'espérance d'un européen je
suis conscient du caractère un peu
provocateur de ce titre par les temps
qui courent mais je l'assumé avec un
certain nombre d'entre vous
bon d'abord j'ai peut-être deux choses
très simples mais le président de
voumard été si je m'éloigne de l'objet
de l'audition
d'abord j'ai voulu raconter l'europe du
terrain telle que je la vis dans mon
village sarrois ou dans
ce que j'ai vu en italie dans mon métier
précédent je crois que l'europe est
beaucoup trop facilement abstraite
ramené à des querelles institutionnelles
qui n'intéresse pas grand monde alors
qu'ils se passent de telles choses
passionnantes en europe y compris des
réformes chez nos voisins qui peuvent
être utiles pour nous
et puis
donc c'est une approche très pratique
mais si j'ai voulu exprimé une
conviction je pense que beaucoup d'entre
nous peuvent s'y retrouver c'est qu'au
fond je pense que l'identité européenne
se demande toujours ce qu'elle est je
crois qu'elle s'exprime beaucoup à
travers un modèle social et quand j
modèle social je dis pas nécessairement
conservatisme et absence de réforme mais
au fond ce qui réunit les pays européens
dans leur carte d'identité quand vous le
regardez dans les chiffres c'est qu'ils
ont des services publics forts et qu'
ils ont des inégalités plus faible que
le monde américain ou que le monde
émergent et c'est vrai à travers les
différents pays européens et c'est vrai
à travers les différents bords
politiques je crois que l'opinion
européenne a des préférences collectives
pour cela
une fois que j'ai dit cela la deuxième
partie du message est évidemment
essentiel c'est que ce modèle social
européen
peut être compatible avec le succès dans
la mondialisation économique au prix de
réformes et que nous avons souvent nous
l'impression français que nous sommes
condamnés à choisir entre notre modèle
social et le succès économique je crois
qu'un certain nombre de nos voisins et
pas seulement l'allemagne montrent que
une trajectoire de réformes poursuivie
sur la durée avec constance est un
chemin pour rendre compatible le modèle
social européen et le succès dans la
mondialisation pardon d'être aussi
rapide sur des sujets qu'ils
appelleraient de développement plus long
mais
évidemment je crois que nous sommes
nombreux à souhaiter ici que notre pays
puisse poursuivre amplifier ce chemin
sur lequel sur lequel nous sommes
voilà j'espère avoir par ailleurs
répondu au shadow banking
et beaucoup je vais donner la parole
maintenant à eric moquer il sera suivi
de philippe dominati et de maurice
vincent éric bocquet bien merci madame
la présidente bien monsieur villeroy de
galhau une nomination à ce poste n'est
ni une affaire banale ni même simplement
technique c'est une fonction
prestigieuse est important que les
institutions fondamentales dans ce pays
alors votre candidature vous l'avez
évoqué a suscité déjà des commentaires
un peu de polémique parfois et parmi les
commentaires récurrents a été évoqué ce
risque de conflit d'intérêts si vous
devenez gouverneur de la banque de
france vous allez présider par exemple
la cpr l'autorité de contrôle prudentiel
résolution celle là même qui infligea à
la banque dont vous fûtes l'un des
grands responsables une amende de 10
millions d'euros me semble-t-il pour des
problèmes domestiques cette fois des
dossiers de contrats d'assurance vie en
déshérence 6 - informations sont exactes
alors vous avez d'emblée tenté de couper
court à toute polémique en adressant un
courrier 1 par rapport à cette
thématique des taux d'intérêt donc
madame la présidente de la commission et
son homologue de l'assemblée nationale
la presse s'en est fait l'écho donc vous
avez répété ici certains des engagements
vous aviez pris je les rappelle vous
indiquez donc que vous ne percevrez y
ait aucune rémunération différée de la
bnp paribas c'est bien de le dire mais
je pense que ça allait de choix vous
engagez à ne plus détenir aucune action
de votre ancienne banque par contre vous
précisez que vous ne pourriez pas céder
immédiatement les actions de performance
pour des raisons légales apparemment
avant mars 2016 et enfin vous avez
déclarez vous l'avez réaffirmer ici que
vous ne participerions aucune décision
individuelle concernant votre ancienne
banque dans un délai de deux années
toutes ces dispositions organiques aller
de soi mais dans le même temps elle
montre bien que votre candidature à ce
poste poser de vraies questions éthiques
nous avons ce soir à nous prononcer non
pas tant sur votre personne et insistent
mais sur des principes en v en vigueur
dans une république qui se doit d'être
exemplaire est présenté en toutes
circonstances toutes les garanties
d'impartialité
je voudrais ici évoqué la récente
décision du tribunal correctionnel de
paris dans le dossier bp ce monsieur
pérol en ne faisant aucun lien bien sûr
outre votre situation et celle là il n'y
a aucun lien du tout aucun parallèle
dans mon esprit mon intention n'est pas
de faire du tout ce parallèle mais
désormais jugé donc on n'y revient pas
mais au delà de la décision finale
quelques mots de commenter du tribunal
que j'aurais citer ici
le tribunal a souligné cette singulière
porosité entre secteur privé et secteur
public et la parente familiarité avec
laquelle les plus proche collaborateur
d'un ministre sont traités vous avez été
rappelons le directeur de cabinet d'un
ministre de l'économie et quelques
années donnent l'apparence d'une
connivence pour des affaires privées
particulièrement regrettable au titre du
respect dû aux institutions de la
république c'était dans le monde du 26
septembre dernier donc messieurs le
gallo ne sommes pas au tribunal je le
répète avec clarté nous sommes ici dans
une institution de la république donc
que pensez vous de cette analyse là ma
première question enfin pour conclure
notre commission en a régulièrement à se
prononcer sur des propositions de
candidatures à ce type de fonction et il
nous faut bien faire le constat les uns
et les autres que ces candidatures sont
très souvent pour ne pas dire toujours
issu de la banque privée j'ai en tête la
collector de madame le moineau au
conseil des finances publiques celle
plus récente de madame plagnol au même
au conseil des finances publiques qui
était passée elle au crédit suisse
banque privée et hsbc évidemment les
critères mis en avance mises en avant
sont la compétence l'expertisé soit on
peut en convenir mais n'y aurait-il de
compétences que chez les personnalités
issues de la finance privée c'est ma
deuxième question est donc je réaffirme
à nouveau afin d'éviter tout procès
d'intention que je m'exprime ici sur des
principes et non pas à dominer merci au
quai philippe dominati ensuite maurice
vincent
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
dans cette même salle il y à quelques
temps nous avions auditionné monsieur
jean-pierre juillet lorsqu'il voulait
exercer des fonctions à la caisse des
dépôts et consignations et je m'étais
étonné parce qu'ils voulaient
effectivement avoir des restrictions
dans son mandat et il avait pris
l'engagement devant la commission des
finances de ne pas prendre deux postes
dans les filiales de la caisse des
dépôts et des consignations
et cet engagement était très rapidement
levé puisqu'il va quelque peu de temps
après il avait été je crois nommé
administrateur ou au conseil
d'administration de l'ess cnp et
heureusement heureusement parce que je
trouve que on ne peut pas limité dans
ses fonctions parce qu'on ne peut pas
prédire l'avenir
sur des postes aussi important et je
voulais donc simplement faire une
observation en ce qui me concerne c'est
que je souhaite monsieur villeroy de
galhau que vous soyez des lié à mes yeux
de cet engagement dans cette lettre
parce qu' elle n'a pas vraiment de sens
parce que s'il y avait une crise
importante je souhaite que vous soyez
pleinement en toute indépendance
gouverneur et donc je trouve que c'est
restrictif et votre indépendance est
absolument nécessaire je m'étais étonné
lors de cette audition d'ailleurs ça
avait été très rapidement levé par
monsieur jean pierre juillet cet
engagement pris devant la commission des
finances et il n'y a pas eu de
conséquence autre que même pas une
simple réflexion ou autre alors que vaut
un engagement de ce type il est pour la
forme mais en réalité il ne doit en
aucun cas altérer les fonctions de celui
qui est nommé s'il est agréé évidemment
par les commissions des finances des
deux assemblées sur un sujet aussi
important parce qu'autrement nous irons
au fur et à mesure dans des nominations
je dirais peut-être parcellaires ou
conditionnelle ou à tempérament et donc
je pense que ce n'est absolument pas
souhaitable
philippe dominati mots et cela sans
merci bien de la présidente je reviens à
des questions
de politique économique et financière
je voulais vous vous demandez si au
moment où nous nous trouvons vous ne
pensez pas qu une impulsion plus forte
sur la demande est nécessaire au niveau
de l'économie française et de l'économie
européenne
j'ai noté que dans votre rapport sur le
financement de l'investissement vous
saisit effectivement un certain nombre
de propositions mais plutôt orientées
dans le sens d'une amélioration des
conditions de financement de l'économie
plutôt que une impulsion en faveur de la
demande à l'exception des mesures que
vous évoquez du plan d'une coeur il me
semble que après les efforts qui ont été
faits notamment dans notre pays pour
restaurer la situation financière des
entreprises et en tenant compte des
prévisions de croissance économique
moi j'ai le sentiment que nous arrivons
un peu à une situation d'une forme de
butoir est que si l'on veut essayer de
provoquer une croissance économique un
peu plus forte qui est indispensable à
mon sens dans les années à venir il faut
se poser la question des instruments
dont on dispose pour
essayer de renforcer la demande
monsieur villeroy de galhau si vous
voulez bien répondre à ses trois
collègues
les deux premières questions du sénateur
bloqué du sénateur demint et voilà touch
de première intervention
touche à mon statut personnel
monsieur lequel je veux tout de suite
répondre aux 2 questions vous avez posé
n'irait-il de compétences qui sut de la
banque privée la réponse est évidemment
non
il se trouve que
trois des anciens gouverneurs de banque
de france sont tous trois
jean claude trichet michel camdessus et
jacques de larosière sont tous trois
issus purement du service public j'ai
été d'autant plus sensible que fait qu
ayant regardé mes engagements ils disent
qu un parcours mixte comme le mien leur
part est compatible pleinement avec la
compétence et l'indépendance dans
l'exercice des fonctions
je précise par ailleurs que dans ma vie
professionnelle
relativement longue aujourd'hui j'ai
passé deux tiers dans le service public
et un tiers dans la banque dans la
banque de détail et que tous ceux qui me
connaissent je les dis dans mon propos
liminaire mais
savent que la fibre du service public et
profonde en moi
je ne crois pas en ayant été banquier de
détail en france et en europe y avoir
mon être à ce point éloigné
par ailleurs
à propos de la décision
m
du tribunal correctionnel dit pérol vous
avez dit qu'il s'agissait d'un cas
différent je ferai évidemment aucun
commentaire sur la décision je souligne
juste que ces deux cas effectivement
totalement différent dans un cas il
s'agit du passage du public vers une
responsabilité bancaire avec un droit
applicable dans mon cas voilà il s'agit
de quitter la banque et tous les liens
que je pouvais y avoir pour
permettez-moi de le dire comme ça me
remette au service de mon pays ça
représente un certain nombre de choix de
renoncement je trouve ça normal
totalement normal je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs au début sur les engagements
que j'ai pu prendre ce n'est néanmoins
pas si fréquent et j'espère avoir été de
la plus de la plus grande clarté là
dessus alors au delà de ces deux
questions de principe j'aurais peut-être
préciser le fonctionnement de la cpr
puisque vous avez posé la question des
sanctions et ce faisant répondre à
monsieur dominati
d'abord la lettre d'engagement que je
vous ai envoyé
résulte d'une étude assez précise que
j'ai faite de l'ensemble des
dispositions existent en droit français
que j'ai bien sûr partagé avec un
certain nombre de juristes
et le principe a été très simple j'ai
pris l'ensemble des dispositions qui
existait en droit français et je les ai
ajouté les et cumulé si vous en effet la
réunion au sens mathématique du terme
ce qui peut expliquer l'engagement sur
les deux ans ce que je vais revenir mais
il me semblait que dès qu'il y avait une
disposition je la prenais et je la
mettais dans la lettre je note
d'ailleurs que personne ne m'a proposé
depuis cette lettre un engagement
supplémentaire que je puisse prendre
personne
alors est ce que ceci gêne ou ne gêne
pas l'exercice des fonctions je crois
que non et c'est là que je voudrais
revenir sur le fonctionnement de la cpr
la cpr
fonctionne aujourd'hui avec un collège
présidé par le gouverneur que je serais
éventuellement ce collège regarde les
questions transversales collective
en ce qui concerne les décisions
individuelles y compris des sanctions
dont vous avez parlé elle relève de
trois collèges et un collège bancaires
sur les décisions individuelles
concernant les banques qui est présidée
par un sous gouverneur lui même
indépendant puisqu'il est nommé pour six
ans par décret en conseil des ministres
et donc ça n'est pas de gouverneur pour
ce qui concerne les assurances le
collège est présidée par le
vice-président haddock de la cpr et
enfin points essentiels par rapport à
votre question monsieur le sénateur des
sanctions relève d'une commission des
sanctions qui est présidé par un
conseiller d'état ou deux sièges mal
gouverneur et donc de fait
ça vaut aussi d'ailleurs pour les
décisions de politique monétaire le
gouverneur contenu de l'organisation de
la banque de france n'est pas chauffée
circonstances exceptionnelles je vais y
revenir tout de suite n'est pas sauf
circonstances exceptionnelles en
situation de prendre des décisions
individuelles concernant une mangue
et
j'ai pris donc à titre de précaution
supplémentaire la règle des deux ans
certains m'ont dit ben vous auriez pu
simplement expliquer ce que vous venez
d'expliquer pourquoi j'ai pris à titre
de précaution supplémentaire cette règle
de deux ans parce que selon une
interprétation très rigoureuse de
l'article l 612 10 pardon de ce cette
intrusion technique du code monétaire et
financier il ya une règle d'abstention
de deux ans de ce type qui est prévu
pour la superbe mais je crois que
l'avoir fait ne crée pas de difficultés
pratiques c'est juste une précaution
supplémentaire
reste le cas que vous avez évoquées
monsieur le sénateur en disant mais
qu'est ce qui se passe il ya une crise
grave concernant bnp paribas d'ici le
1er mai 2010 est puisque les deux ans
courait jusque là alors d'abord je pense
qu'aucun d'entre nous ne le souhaite
parce que on est vraiment dans des
circonstances absolument non même à
travers la pire crise financière que
nous ayons connue depuis des décennies
ça ne s'est pas produit
et donc si on était dans une situation
qu'on appelle de résolution c'était la
question de madame la présidente tout à
l'heure
concernant bnp paribas est ce que j'ose
dire avec un sourire parlant de choses
graves qu'à ce moment là il y aurait
probablement des questions beaucoup plus
lourde que mon éventuel conflit
d'intérêts
j'espère que ça ne se produira pas si on
est cya je vais prendre un exemple si ce
produit un contentieux américains comme
celui dont le rapporteur général parlait
tout à l'heure d'ici premier 2017 ça je
ne m'en occuperai bas et je ne crois pas
quelles que soient mes mérites que ça
ferait une énorme différence si on est
dans un cas de résolution de bnp paribas
qu'est vraiment un cas extrême
voilà je n'ose pas dire c'est une
hypothèse infiniment improbable si
jamais elle se présentait je reviendrai
peut-être si vous le souhaitez devant
chacune des deux commissions
disons que souhaitez vous
supposez que mon engagement personnel
fasse une énorme différence dans cette
situation de crise grave mais on est
vraiment je le souligne dans un cas très
extrême et dans les circonstances
normales le gouverneur de la banque de
france n'est pas en situation de devoir
prendre des décisions individuelles
cheminement
merci beaucoup il nous reste deux
collègues inscrit andré gattolin et marc
laménie et j'aurai aussi une question
suite à maurice vincent vous n'avez pas
répondu à maurice vincent brie dans la
question personnelle je n'ai pas répondu
à la question tout à fait essentiel de
monsieur vincent
alors votre question portent évidemment
au delà de la politique monétaire sur la
politique budgétaire est et ce qu'on
peut faire
je me limite de 3 réflexion rapide
j'espère que nous aurons l'occasion
d'autres d'autres dialogues là dessus
premièrement
j'ai parlé à propos de nos débats
économiques je me méfie parfois comme
vous des débats peu trop simplifié qui
nous oppose entre l'offre et la demande
je crois que le bon sens qui réunit qui
nous réunit c'est à dire qu'il faut une
politique d'offres et une politique de
deux morts et elles sont évidemment
complémentaires j'y reviendrai à propos
du thème de l'investissement ou ceci me
paraît clair
néanmoins dans la situation où nous
sommes aujourd'hui puisque votre
question était conjoncturelle
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
facteurs favorables à la demande qui
joue déjà c'est le prix du pétrole très
bas c'est l' inflation très faible on
parlait monsieur le sénateur young et
qui se traduit par une évolution du
pouvoir d'achat qui est plutôt favorable
c'est une bonne nouvelle nous avons des
gains de pouvoir d'achat d'un peu plus
de 1% par an en france sur la période
c'est évidemment les taux d'intérêt très
bas etc
et nous voyons que ces circonstances
favorables entraînent un mieux
conjoncturel c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais ne suffisent pas à enclencher une
franche reprise
et donc je crois que la question
centrale de politique qu'économique que
nous avons c'est comment nous
transformons ce mieux conjoncturelle qui
tient quand même à des facteurs qui
soutiennent la demande en vraie reprise
durable alimenter et là la clé
l'investissement c'était le sens de mon
rapport
alors l'investissement à ce grand mérite
de réunir les partisans de l'offre et de
la demande parce qu'il peut l'avers et
le revers de la même pièce de monnaie
je crois néanmoins j'ai essayé de citer
un certain nombre de facteurs de
favorable à l'investissement
mon rapport était sur le financement
mais j'ai dis honnêtement que la plupart
des facteurs n'était pas financer son
économie que vous le disiez dans votre
question il ya bien sûr la demande
anticipée on retrouve l'ambivalence mais
il ya deux éléments absolument clé
notamment en france c'est la confiance
des entrepreneurs et tout ce qui peut
être fait autour de la simplification et
je crois essentiel pour cela et la
stabilité des règles et des normes et
puis il ya la rentabilité non pas au
sens un peu mécanique ou était autrefois
le théorème de schmidt
vous vous souvenez que nous apprenions
en disant voilà les profits
d'aujourd'hui sont les investissements
de demain font les emplois d'après
demain ça je crois que c'est une vision
un peu simpliste de l'économie parce
qu'il ya d'autres leviers de
l'investissement
mais cependant notamment pour les pme je
crois que leurs perspectives de
rentabilité sont un des trois
déclencheur économique de
l'investissement de ce point de vue il
me semble que ce qui est fait alors qui
est jugé insuffisant ou excessifs sont
les bords mais ce qui a été fait autour
du pacte de responsabilité du cic eux va
dans le bon sens pour l'investissement
des entreprises et donc la consolidation
de la croissance pardon d'avoir été à la
fois un peu long et un peu rapide mais
c'est évidemment une question clé est
important que nourrisse pas sans réponse
également andré gattolin sera suivi de
marc laménie mais merci madame la
présidente monsieur les droits de galop
la question que je me pose parce qu'on a
beaucoup évoqué
pas seulement ici mais en amont de cette
présentation le risque de conflit
d'intérêts moi je m'intéresse aussi
beaucoup au risque peut-être de
conformisme dans en matière financière
et bancaire jeu souvenirs
suivant beaucoup la presse américaine au
moment de la crise des subprimes ou le
discours général était dire la crise non
tout va se régler il n'y a pas de gros
risques et quand je vois aujourd'hui la
situation internationale
l'évolution de l'économie chinoise et
les problèmes financiers qui suivent
l'inquiétude quant à une répercussion
sur l'ensemble de nos économies mais
aussi de nos systèmes financiers est
importante et vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure dans votre exposé l'évolution et
les avancées d'union bancaire est un peu
rapidement vous avez dit le mécanisme de
résolution ça c'est fait le vrai souci
c'est que le fonds de résolution unique
est prévue pour être abondée pendant
huit ans il ya d'un volume de 50
milliards d'euros donc si une crise
survenait dans les six mois ou dans
l'année à venir je comprends que dans
toute position de personnes responsables
on va pas mettre crier au feu en disant
attention la situation est inquiétante
mais à force de dire ce risque n'est pas
important et c est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de se passer à côté de quelque
chose et à ce propos d'ailleurs à
l'initiative du parlement et notamment
du sénat ce qui devait être initialement
prévu a été modifié sur le modèle
allemand c'est-à-dire que les banques
françaises verront leur contribution non
déductibles donc à hauteur des 15
milliards qui sont engagés alors je
voudrais savoir vous connaissant bien
l'univers de la banque et des grandes
banques françaises est ce que vous
pensez que c'est une décision juste que
nous avons poussé à faire prendre au
gouvernement celle de la non
déductibilité quel cas aussi en
allemagne ou si vous pensez au contraire
que c'est un handicap supplémentaire
pour nos grandes banques je vous
remercie merci marc laménie oui merci
madame la présidente très rapidement
parce que je crois beaucoup de choses
ont été dites et vous êtes largement
très intervenu sur beaucoup de domaines
dont notamment la compétence en
particulier sur l'impartialité à moi en
question n'a pas été évoquée mais c'est
le
quelles seraient les vos perspectives
comme concernant la présence de la
banque de france sur nos territoires sur
nos départements parce que
on rencontre souvent bold le directeur
de la banque de france jean présente un
petit département les ardennes mais il
ya aussi une présence humaine et qui est
très importante parce que bon au moins
pour le soutien des entreprises
notamment les entreprises en difficulté
et je manque la présence sur le
département et est fondamental donc
c'était ma modeste question
mais moi j'ai une caisse deux questions
complémentaires monsieur
c'est au tour de deux des chambres de
compensation
elle constitue aussi un facteur de
risque systémique dans la mesure où
elles sont susceptibles de menacer
l'équilibré des marchés
comment peut-on garantir que ces
chambres de compensation constituent
effectivement les factures de stabilité
la banque centrale européenne ne
risque-t-elle pas de devoir se courir
des chambres de compensation en cas de
crise grande ampleur et j'aimerais
savoir quel jugement vous portez si vous
avez vous aviez
observer cette affaire sur la décision
de la cour de justice de l'union
européenne qui en mars dernier avec
débouté la bce qui souhaitait que les
chambres de compensation et à une
activité significative en euros sont
obligatoirement localisé dans la zone
euro et puis j'ai une autre question sur
concerne votre rapport sur le
financement de l'investissement des
entreprises que j'ai personnellement
beaucoup apprécié vous proposez pour
favoriser le développement des nouveaux
contrats d'assurance-vie euro croissance
d'autoriser des transferts de richesse
entre fonds en euros et supports euros
croissance savez vous si la cpr serait
susceptible d'accueillir favorablement
une telle proposition
oui monsieur gattolin sur le risque de
conformisme
je peux pas vous donner de garantie
absolue en la matière j'ai insisté sur
le fait j'étais un homme libre
je crois que la diversité
de mon expérience si j'ose dire deux
tiers services publics français et
européens et un tiers bancaire va
peut-être donner une certaine ouverture
est aussi une certaine diversité
d'opinion
voilà après je crois que personne n'est
à l'abri du conformisme et jeu j'y
veillerai
je vous invite peut-être à regarder
certaines parties de mon rapport y
compris un point qui a été peut noter
que j'en profite qui est ce que j'ai
écrit sur le coût du capital ou ce que
les américains appellent le cost of
equity je pense c'est une approche assez
nouvelle d'une problématique qui se pose
aujourd'hui aux états unis pas trop en
europe heureusement mais qui pauvre
monsieur le sénateur vincent peser sur
l'investissement là je revendique pas un
brevet de non conformisme mais il ya une
partie assez innovante il y en a
quelques autres
vous avez au delà de s'imposer la
question du fonds de résolution je crois
en réponse à la question de même le
président tout à l'heure avoir introduit
une nuance en disant que c'était très
bien que ce deuxième pilier existe mais
qui n'était pas tout à fait terminé et
là je vous rejoins c'est la montée en
puissance progressive
et que peut-être terminée plus vite ce
pilier résolution simplifierait ou
diversifierait les discussions ce
troisième pilier c'est à dire la
garantie des dépôts
bon s'est néanmoins très grands progrès
parce que je crois juste
ça aurait été bien sans doute que ça
arrive plus vite et si ça peut aller
plus vite ça sera une très bonne chose
mais je crois juste que l'europe et
définit des règles qui protègent bien
davantage les contribuables à venir et
qui met à contribution les créanciers et
tout ça s'est passé sans l'écroulement
du marché des créances bancaires qui
était annoncé par certains alors sur la
décision sur les contributions non
déductibles ça je crois que c'est une
décision de politique fiscale donc elle
appartient très légitimement parlement
et je n'ai pas à la commenter vous savez
que du côté des banques
provoqué un certain nombre de cris
stridents et chiffré jeu pour vous dire
je le dis peut-être avec humour ou
sourire je peux vous dire que cette
seule décision a mis à bas la
compétitivité des banques françaises je
crois que c'est très exagéré
néanmoins et je lis avec la même liberté
que les autres points que j'ai évoquée
depuis le début de cette audition je
crois simplement qu'il faut que nous
soyons attentifs à trouver un bon point
d'équilibré sur la compétitivité des
banques françaises
qui sont aussi facteur d'emplois et de
et de bons financements mais sur les
contributions déductibles j'ai pas je je
n'ai pas de remarque particulière à
faire je crois que ça correspondait
d'ailleurs à l'alignement sur le statut
d'autres cotisations relativement
proches dans leur statut
monsieur le sénateur laménie sur la
présence dans les territoires j'ai
assisté assez fortement dans mon propos
liminaire à propos de ce que j'ai appelé
les missions de service économique c'est
vrai qu'on en parle quelques fois moins
que la mission monétaire mais ça me
paraît une très grande chance de la
banque de france de voir les deux quand
je disais les pieds sur le terrain et la
tête dans l'europe
alors nous savons en même temps qu'il
faut adapter le réseau à l'évolution des
missions
et qu'un certain de mission je pense à
la circulation des billets par exemple
ne s'exerce pas aujourd'hui de la même
manière qu'eux il ya 15 ans mais la
banque de france a adopté un plan dit
réseau 2020 dont on ne sait pas encore
en situation de vous décrire tous les
détails mais qui me paraît en gros tracé
un bon équilibre c'est à dire essayer de
faire des gains d'efficacité et c'est
aussi un service rendu à la collectivité
nationale parce que ça nourrit la
contribution financière de la banque de
france au budget mais mais maintenir une
présence visible active dans chaque
département et vous avez cité je vous en
remercie le rôle du directeur de la
banque de france dans chaque département
se simpar un rôle extrêmement important
je souhaite le conforter peut-être le
développer encore j'ai parlé du débat
économique peut-être de la pédagogie
économique je crois que la banque de
france peut beaucoup aider à
l'information économique dans nos
territoires
à participer à un certain nombre de
débats et puis au service rendu aux pme
jeudi un tout petit mot à ce propos de
la cotation qui a quelquefois mauvaise
presse parce que pour certaines
entreprises leur cotation banque de
france n'est pas exactement ce que nous
aurait souhaité il reste je peux vous le
dire après avoir fait la comparaison
européenne dans le cas de mon rapport
que l'existence de cette cotation des
pme sur l'ensemble du territoire est un
atout unique de la france au sein de
l'eurosystème et que ceci va faciliter
la diversification dont nous parlions
tout à l'heure en réponse à une question
de monsieur le sénateur bouvard des
financeurs non bancaires le feront
d'autant plus facilement financeront
d'autant plus facilement les pme qu'ils
disposent de la cotation de la banque de
france donc ça c'est un service très
important qui doit demeurer et bien sûr
se faire dans le dans le dialogue avec
les entreprises mais je crois que ça
fait partie du soutien des entreprises
dont vous parliez l'autre mission très
importante c'est la médiation j'ai
proposé dans mon rapport des pistes à
propos des tpe je crois qu'on peut faire
on peut faire un peu plus
alors madame la présidente votre
question sur les chambres de
compensation
vous me permettrez
de passer la première partie de la
question sur le facteur de stabilité
parce qu'objectivement aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas encore un sujet que je connais
assez bien pour faire une réponse étayé
mais évidemment je le regarderai
rapidement pour vous revenir sur la
deuxième partie de votre question qui
est la décision de la cour de justice
des communautés européennes je crois que
nous l'avons tous regretté puisque
l'enjeu était effectivement d'obtenir
que ces chambres de compensation soient
situées en zone euro et pas à londres
l'arrêt de la cour de justice de ce que
je comprends se font sur des motifs de
procédure et pas sur des motifs de fond
et donc la question qui se pose c'est
est ce qu'on peut voilà réouvrir la
faire autrement avec une autre procédure
je crois simplement que cette question
est devenue évidemment un peu plus
sensible dans le contexte du référendum
britannique et
je prends la même cause de prudent je ne
me prononcerai pas définitivement sur ce
qu'il est souhaitable quand on regarde
l'ensemble du sujet mais trouver à terme
en zone euro des chambres de
compensation efficace c'est évidemment
souhaitable
à propos de l'euro croissance
j'ai évoqué un principe et puis ensuite
prudemment une modalité pour traduire le
principe le principe ça je crois que
nous nous y retrouvons tous y compris
par rapport aux financements plus
dynamiques de l'économie dans plusieurs
d'entre vous ont parlé c'est que
l'assurance vie qui est aujourd'hui le
premier placement des français avec 1600
milliards d'euros doit servir davantage
à financer les entreprises et
l'investissement productif
et donc c'est l'investissement en
actions est de ce point de vue là le
produit euro croissance qui avait été
imaginé en 2014 par le parlement en
liaison avec les professionnels me
paraît un bon produit dont le principe
de base est de dire on renonce à la
liquidité immédiate qu on offre à
l'épargnant mais on lui offre une
garantie en capital sur une durée plus
longue 8 ans
ceci donne à l'assureur une durée
suffisamment longue pour pouvoir
investir sur des produits plus risqués
ces les actions c'est bon pour le
financement d'économie et c'est bon
aussi pour les assurés parce que sur
cette durée normalement le rendement des
actions est supérieur il se trouve et je
vais pas rentrer dans le détail
technique que le démarrage du produit
est décevant est trop lent
notamment essayée à la question que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure sur les taux de
l'assurance vie parce que les taux du
fonds en euros restent beaucoup plus
favorable que les taux les taux d'euros
croissance et c'est là qu'on arrive donc
le principe c'est réussir aux
croissances et je crois que tout le
monde est d'accord la modalité qui a été
évoquée
notamment par certains professionnels et
que j'évoque prudemment c'est quand un
assuré décide de transférer une partie
de ses fonds du fonds euros verrou
croissance est ce qui peut transférer
aussi la part des plus values du fonds
euros à laquelle il a droit juste par là
la discussion est en cours elle inclut
la cpr effectivement
je vous avoue que ces dernières semaines
j'ai un peu moins participer je
comprends que la discussion avance
prudemment techniquement c'est sans
doute comme ça qu'il faut penser d'aimer
ce serait bon d'avoir une réponse je
porte dans les mois qui viennent pour
traduire ce principe sur lequel nous
nous retrouvons tous
mais eh bien
je vais en l'absence d'autres
interventions vous remercier de du temps
que nous avait consacré moins que nous
allons mettre en place le bureau de vote
puisque nous devons émettre un vote à
l'issue de cette audition je remercie
ceux qui ne sont pas sénateur
de bien vouloir nous quitter à notre
grand regret et
je suis vous raccompagner nous allons
mettre en place le bureau de vote les
deux
assesseurs je crois philippe dallier
françois marquis accepter tous les deux
ans secrétaire de la commission ce rôle
important merci encore